[Music]
God may he be exalted said to me do you
know who you are I replied yes I am the
non-being
which is manifested by your
manifestation
I am the darkness which your light
illuminates then he said to me since you
know this persevere firmly in this
knowledge and be careful not to claim
that which does not belong to you for
the deposit must be returned to its
owner and the loan must be paid back the
name contingent being has always
belonged to you and always will belong
to you he said to me again do you know
who you are I replied yes I am in
reality God but metaphorically and in
relation to the way I am creature I am a
contingent being with respect to my form
but I cannot not be the necessary being
it is the divine name on Huk which
belongs to me by original rites the name
of creature is only a borrowed name and
a formula of differentiation he said to
me veil this symbol and let the wall
fall down and bury this treasure in
order that only he will be able to
extract it who has put his soul through
severe trials and looked his death in
the face then God may he be exalted said
to me what are you I replied I am two
things according to two different
relations with respect to you I am the
eternal for ever and ever
I am the necessary being who epitomizes
himself - Esther he proceeds from the
necessity of your essence and my
eternity from the eternity of your
knowledge and your attributes
with respect to me I am pure non-being
who has never breathed the perfume of
existence the adventitious being who
remains non-existence and his
adventitious news
I only possess being so long as I am
present with you and for you left to
myself and absent from you I am one who
is not even while he is then he said to
me and Who am I
I replied you are the being necessary
through yourself alone perfect in its
essence and its attributes
better yet you transcend by the
perfection of your essence the
perfection of your attributes you are
the perfect in every state the
transcendent with respect to everything
which can come to the mind he replied to
me you do not know me I said to him
without fear being disrespectful you are
he in whose likeness all contingent
creatures are you our Lord and the
servant the near and the far you are the
one and the multiple the sublime and the
lowly the rich and the poor the
worshipper and the worship to the
contemplate ER and the contemplated in
you are joined the contraries and the
opposites for you are the apparent and
the hidden the Voyager and the sedentary
he is souls and he who cultivates you
are he who plays her tricks and who
deceives you are the supreme reality and
I am the supreme reality you are
creature and I am creature you are
neither this nor that and I am neither
this nor that he said to me that is
enough you know me hide me from those
who know me not for lordship has a
secrets and if it were revealed lordship
would be annihilated and servitude also
has a secret and if it were revealed
servitude will be annihilated praise us
for what we have taught you about our
self for you cannot know us by any other
than us nothing leads to us except our
self
you
[Music]